the research on on couples is such that
most couples therapists
can watch
like a five-minute
snippet of a couple argue
and predict a divorce with accuracies of
over 90
oh
that's rough
hmm
as a therapist i tend to think it's
great but okay yes
but it's not for the couple who's
arguing in that way why but why that is
is because it is how couples argue
that gives you a window into the
relationship satisfaction and longevity
it's how they process conflict and
there's several factors that have been
shown to you know bode well for couples
versus bold poorly for couples
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 111 with guy winch guy
wench is a psychologist and author and
host of his own psychology podcast he
specializes in the topics of trauma
heartbreak and couples relationships
he's written several self-help books and
co-hosts a podcast called dear
therapists
which is pretty entertaining
i wanted to speak with him about the
subject of heartbreak how to heal a
broken heart he authored how to fix a
broken heart
for anyone having a hard time in your
relationship or trying to get over
someone this might help
again like i said last episode this is
an episode from about a month ago when
things were a bit crazy in my life i'll
be doing a q a soon to update everyone
and things are much better now i hope
you enjoy this episode and have a
fantastic week
if you enjoy this content please
remember to hit subscribe
[Music]
dr guy winch welcome to my podcast
thank you so much for having me
i'm very excited to talk to you
i had somebody on instagram reach out
and say you have to get
this guy on
he knows everything about relationships
and heartbreak
and trauma and i've been on a
how to deal with trauma kick
but i thought for this episode we should
talk specifically about
relationships and heartbreak
but before we get started could you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
so i'm a psychologist and i also write
books i have three self-help books um i
also have three ted talks um and i have
a podcast called dear therapists with
co-host lori gottlieb in which we um
have guests write us letters in which
they need advice but we bring them on
for actual kind of therapy session live
and then we give them advice and then
they have to do it and report back on
how it went so you kind of get a full
arc of the story each week
oh that's interesting so you talk to
people and they come back on the podcast
to tell you how it's going and to tell
the audience yeah but not just that when
we do it we don't talk about the case
beforehand so my co-host and i we have
to jump in as two therapists blind not
knowing what the other one thinks and
try and navigate it to an interesting
place and so it's it's uh interesting
all along
that is interesting
okay
okay so you have a number of self-help
books your most recent one what was your
most recent one about called how to fix
a broken heart it had a has a ted talk
of the same
name and it's about really
what happens to us when we have romantic
heartbreak um because a lot happens to
us
okay so let's start there then um i
remember
when i was
i suppose this happens to everybody
somewhat but when i was little like in
grade nine or ten and had my first real
relationship and i thought i was going
to grow up and get married to him
and was 100
certain that was going to happen and
when we broke up i was just distraught
like unbelievably distraught so what
does happen um with heartbreak
so
two things actually first of all what's
interesting about heartbreak is that
thing that happened to you in ninth or
tenth grade happens to us in our 20s and
our 30s and our 40s we get similarly
distraught
um at all ages and i've worked with
heartbroken people of all ages it kind
of doesn't matter how old you are if
you're truly heartbroken you are
heartbroken
and what's interesting about heartbreak
is that there is no other common
experience in life because right
heartbreak is not something you'll see
in the diagnostic and statistical manual
of mental disorders there's no such
thing
so it's just a life experience there is
no life experience like it in which can
take somebody who has no psychological
problems
and render them non-functional and
almost a little bit crazy
in a blink
that's what's so fascinating about it
there's no other thing
that grief can make us you know very
very upset but we don't act out of sorts
we don't lose our minds and do things we
would never do otherwise we do with
heartbreak
okay so grief and heartbreak are
separate
they're separate i mean i
heartbreak is a form of grief it's one
that we don't recognize so much as a
sanctioned form of grief like we do
losing a first degree relative but our
reactions are as powerful and if you
recall back to that time you said you
were distraught people do get devastated
they feel like they've lost their worlds
they can even as adults they can sit in
bed and not be able to eat or sleep or
function for days
on end that's all they can think about
they they will do desperate acts they
would never otherwise do and you're like
what is wrong with me that i'm doing
this but i'm just so desperate
and so yeah it really does a number on
us
okay so can we talk a bit about exactly
what happened like why is it that
sometimes
you're in a relationship and then you
this happens to you and you're
distraught and kind of insane like you
said
why is it that
why is it that that happens sometimes
and what exactly is happening is it
cortisol or
just on that level so what functional
mri studies what brain scans have showed
is that um the same thing roughly the
same thing happens to our brain when our
love is removed when the person we love
is removed from our life or they remove
themselves usually from our lives um as
happens when heroin addicts
are um
withdrawing from heroin
and if you think about it that way it
kind of explains it because if you think
of a heroin addict who was withdrawing
yeah they would they would steal they
would do all kinds of terrible things
they would never otherwise do but
everyone goes well they were an addict
so that's how desperate they were as if
that explains and she does it explains
the level of desperation the level of
of change and behavior it's the same
mechanisms that are getting activated
when we're heartbroken and it's that
same level of absolute desperation
that you would see happening
uh for an addict so so that's the why i
mean when you look at the brain the
brain's acting very similar and it's
at least explains why people are so out
of sorts
so is that
is that for specifically like an opiate
withdrawal or is that just withdrawal
in general the analogy was to opiate
withdrawals uh opiate uh withdrawal even
to cocaine withdrawal but to like real
substance withdrawal that you really you
know are looking for and i think the
opiate just kind of people associate
that behavior with yeah drug addictions
are like oh yeah i know what that looks
like well it looks the same it looks the
same really is the
the shocking but unreasonable part
okay that's interesting that is kind of
what it feels like right when you're
going through it because you're like i
just want to see something that reminds
me of them again or something like that
just to get some sort of hit
okay
so if you're trying that's why you'll
send 150 text messages just waiting just
to get one word response for that hit
exactly what you said yes
wow okay so what's the best way way to
deal with heartbreak so say you're in a
relationship uh say you've been broken
up with
is it best to go cold turkey then and to
treat it
kind of similar to an addiction
or to wean off how are you supposed to
deal with this well i if it's possible
because sometimes it's not but if it's
possible to do cold turkey i always
recommend cold turkey your goal when
you're heartbroken um is to
stop hurting should be right i mean to
get over the person yeah to get over
them you have to stop hurting to stop
hurting you have to reduce their
presence in your thoughts because right
at the beginning that's 95 percent of
your thoughts is there them then then
then
um the more you reduce that the more
you're moving away from it the more
you're recovering from it the more the
less painful it becomes so that's the
goal so in order to diminish their
presence in your thoughts at the stage
time that you give them
cold turkey is the right way
to go if it's
possible
it's very very difficult to do as any
addict will tell you it's actually it's
actually very difficult to do and what
makes it even more difficult is that
almost in every case
there was a blind side involved and i
say that even in cases in which you know
people say to me like we broke up 10
times over the past two years but i
never expected this one would be the and
i'm like wow you broke up 10 times and
this one
what's that but the thing is that when
when people are looking to break up with
us
they i mean unless they did you know
unless it's you had two or three dates
if it's been anything of any kind of
substance
most people will time it will like
decide okay i want to break up unless
it's a big fight in the moment which is
a minority of cases it's thought through
about when i'll do it and often often
they do it in a considerate way often
they do it because oh you know her big
thing is coming up next week so let's
not do it right before that i'll wait
till after we have this vacation plan
things aren't terrible let's go on that
vacation let's just get through the
holidays and so everything seems fine
until they pull the trigger and then
suddenly like wait what happened things
were fine a day ago
that's true
that's true i suppose it's difficult
with social media now too to not like
you know before if you were in a
different city or you just don't see
them around right and then you're not
thinking about them but now with social
media
and instagram it's a problem
you need to you need to do the great
thing and you need to block and unfollow
and defend even if it's temporarily you
don't want to see what's going on with
them because to remind you they've been
thinking about this for a while so
they're way ahead of you in terms of
recovery and no one puts out there like
here's me crying into a pillow instagram
picture you know they'll find the one
moment where they're happy and post that
meanwhile you're sitting there crying
into a pillow thinking like they're
completely over me well hey they've had
a major head start weeks months
sometimes years of a head start of
getting over you and b
you know again they're putting out this
highly curated image of look i'm fine
everyone
so it's just gonna hurt to see it so
don't don't see it
okay no that makes sense um so does that
mean
say you've been going out with somebody
and you're really good friends with them
and you're no longer romantically
interested
does that mean friendships off the table
for exes
if temporarily i would say i mean i
always say for now
take a few months or however much to
truly get over them now if once you're
truly over them and you know that
because it's not tugging at you in that
way
you want to be friends it doesn't hurt
to be friends go at it but the majority
of people once it gets there are like
that's going to be complicated we don't
i don't need that friendship the friend
excuse and i say excuse is because it is
an excuse at the beginning it's just no
i can be friends without actually having
my guts ripped out every time i talk to
them and no you can't not at the
beginning
okay
fair enough
when
if you're in a relationship with someone
and you're trying to make it work
how do you know
are there signs
that can tell you when you should leave
and when you should keep trying to make
it work
um
that's such a great question
because it depends on all kinds of
variables i mean my general philosophy
is
if you can keep working at it and you
know i mean relationships even ones that
have lasted the 40 50 years are a
constant study and working on things i
mean circumstance changes people you
know change so you're on you constantly
have to shift and tweak and work on
things so my philosophy is if you can
keep working
and oh by the way which means together
not you unilaterally in your head doing
what you think the relationship needs
without the other person participating
in that or being aware of doing it if
you can work and communicate together
for as long as you can
you should unless you're both like we
can but we're both unhappy but
otherwise yeah i mean because i just
think that's the if you have something
invested there why why not
if things are mutual
okay
how do you get over somebody if you
can't stop thinking they were you know
the one person for you or if you tried
dating you know say you went out for
with 15 people just like small dates
some sort of tinder style dating and you
found this one person you had a great
relationship for a few years and you
thought they were the one and then that
falls apart how do you get over the
mindset of
that was the one person that was for me
that's a very hard thing to do but one
thing i always suggest to people is kind
of what you said in other words there's
not the one or my soulmate makes it
sound like you know seven and a half
billion people on the planet i lost
count i think seven and a half whatever
billion people there's one and one that
matches me and it's like
no no they're probably many hundreds of
thousands that match you it took you 15
of those tinder style you know
explorations to find this one maybe
that's your ratio you gotta you know one
in 15 is the one for you all that means
is yeah you got to get out there and
start
getting those numbers in and and finding
the next one once you're free to do that
so people get lost in the thing you know
get trapped into the think it's the only
person it's not the only person it might
be hard for you to find someone
which might be true for you but then all
right then the sooner you start looking
when you feel up to it then it might
take a while but you will if you keep
looking it's hard for you you just have
to generate more options
eventually you will right so so rather
than take the one person as the sign
there's only one take them as no it's
possible to find if i put that much work
into it so now i know how much work i
have to put into it to find it again
once i'm over this person obviously
yeah so how do you know when to get into
the dating market again
you know it's it's tough people always
kind of ask me like how do i know if
it's too soon
yeah i want another date and i basically
well if you can make it through without
crying
is my
scientifically rigorous standard you can
make it through without you know
bursting into tears um you might be
ready because
you know
it part of getting becoming ready is
flexing those muscles again is putting
yourself
out there is you know you know
interacting in that way is flirting and
you know texting and trying to get
banter going i mean that's part of
getting yourself ready is kind of
revisiting those those social muscles
that we don't use when we're in a
relationship as much in that in that
you know to meet someone at least in
that way so it's this thing if you wait
until you're for sure ready you've
waited too long and so
you know as long as you think you know
what i think i might be interested in
someone you don't have to be ready
emotionally fully you can say to a
person i'm recently out of a
relationship i want to take this slow
but if there's someone who released on
paper even though theoretically seems
that might be interesting to you
then take it slowly and see you know
again if you're too preoccupied you're
not paying attention to what the
person's saying and you certainly don't
talk about it yes you know on those
states it's a definite rule don't don't
discuss it because that'll be a you know
it's not good but um it's not attractive
and it'll trigger you um but if you can
get if you can do that then try it out
trial and error
okay i would say that's that's sound
advice
i haven't been
like
dating around for a very long time so i
don't know what the dating market looks
like now but how do you feel about how
people are meeting each other nowadays i
mean given the given covid too things
have gotten a little weird in the last
couple years but even before that with
like i mentioned tinder whatever other
app people are using
where you kind of just see this snapshot
and you're doing like swiping right and
left
is that
is that okay is that healthy are there
problems with that or your views on that
i think my views are mixed i think most
people even the user's views are mixed
in some way there's i mean the number
one
pro
of the apps is convenience
you know
when i was you know a teenager young
adult it was before social media you
actually had to go somewhere
yeah you know you actually had to be in
a bar or be at this or or be somewhere
um where you
will meet someone and then you actually
get to see them in person and this whole
issue of chemistry is a little clearer
because you've actually met them in
person rather than seen just pictures or
videos or whatever so there was an
advantage to that um the convenience
says you can do this from your own home
the inconveniences
that
there's so many people on there who are
not really looking to meet who are
really just there because they just want
to you know get the attention or they
just want to pass the time or they just
want to stick it to the person there
with by going on there like people have
very different or they're about to go on
a trip for a month so just before they
go but really they're not available
so you're wading through a lot of people
who seem to be available but actually
are not
and that you don't know until you're
doing all the swiping and then people
aren't responding and you're like it
must be me and it's like a lot of the
times there's nothing to do with you
they're actually not available or
they're actually not there for that
they're not really serious about meeting
you know they just want to kind of see
what's out there almost like they're you
know reading the newspaper they're not
really serious about it so you don't
know and you have to yeah all of the all
of those people to maybe find the people
who are serious
this episode is brought to you by true
local true local partners with local
farmers and butchers in your area to
source the best meat and deliver it to
your door things like 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished beef pasture-raised or
rwa chicken raised without antibiotics
lamb bison liver and more i recommend
their grain-fed beef i think it tastes
better wild salmon and their lamb is
bomb
they also have over 100 different cuts
of meat that you can't find at your
grocery store most likely to get started
just go to true local t-r-u-local
dot c-a for canadians or t-r-u-local usa
dot com for americans to build your own
personalized box of meat shows up at
your door vacuum sealed and individually
portioned which is perfect for meal prep
also buy an air fryer
just throw those steaks in frozen that's
the biggest life hack i have
use code mp to get free steak in your
order at truelocal.ca or trulocalusa.com
free stakes i hope you enjoy the rest of
this episode
have you heard about ways to date that's
more effective than tinder dating or
something like that given the fact that
a lot of people on those apps are hell
some of them are even in relationships
and they're just like curious so they're
not actually looking for something
long-term are there long-term dating
strategies that you'd recommend
yeah look the one thing i always
recommend is that what is the thing that
you are passionate about what is the
thing that you
you know really feels like a part of you
it's something that you engage in it's
part of your identity you might be a
runner you might be you know into this
band you might be a sports fan you might
be in a sports team you might whatever
it is you might enjoy this kind of
concert or this kind of art if you find
a way to engage in that
with other people
then the people you are likely to meet
there at least have one thing in common
with you you're both passionate or
you're both interested in making
something and i use running just because
for runners it's actually a big you know
if you're a runner then you spend many
hours a week
running obviously and so that's a lot of
hours that if you met somebody in a
running group that you have in common
and so and that's a great way to know
someone so if you can like two birds
with one stone if you can like dual
purpose it and do the thing that
interests you in the first place and
perhaps there meet the person who is
interested in the same thing
that i think is a great way to to meet
somebody in person
then you have things in common as well
right off the bat one and it's a passion
yeah
okay how do you feel about couples who
date each other who have nothing in
common
um you mean the ones that show up in my
therapy office uh yeah
yeah probably yeah because that's what
often
happens um
couples are sometimes together because
of circumstance right they met in
college or they were working together
and and that circumstance made them feel
like there was a lot in common but
remove the circumstance and there's not
it turns out and and you get couples of
really all couples who've met young and
just grown apart and you feel like well
their lives are about all of these
things and the other person's lies about
a whole lot of other things and there's
so little over that
there's so little that they're truly
interested in with one another those are
the couples that are most likely to
drift emotionally from one another
and to start to feel lonely even though
they are together because loneliness
happens a lot within relationships and
it can be profound but it happens within
relationships but but that's what you
would expect because that area of
overlap that communication kind of
you know kind of just like fizzles out
because there's just not that much
binding them
i've spoken to some other people on the
podcast i can't remember who and i've
asked a similar question which is what
happens if the person you're with is
very different from you and there isn't
a lot in common and some people said it
makes it more interesting but i think
your way
your thoughts might be more accurate but
is yeah what do you do okay so what if
you're in a relationship with someone
you guys don't have a lot of overlap is
there a way to fix that
yes now look what a lot of time happens
is that when people have kids that
becomes the common that becomes the
common oh so have children
no no no no no no because
you know when the kids are older and
when the kids leave they're back to like
uh well yeah and why am i with you so it
doesn't you know that no i mean that
often happens empty nest is often or
even not you have to wait emptiness kids
are teenagers they're not interested in
you as much they want to be their
friends and so yeah look at each other
like
oh wow we have to have conversation
tonight uh you know that so and it's but
you can be very different but you can
still have overlap you can still have
very meaningful conversation you can be
a couple who talk together about all
kinds of things even if you
are not you know they're interested in
ex you're interested in why but you're
open to hearing about theirs and they're
open to hearing about yours and they
support you and theirs and you support
them in yours and there can be overlap
there they can be overlapped socially
you might really have one kind of
purpose or one kind of value or one kind
of belief that really binds you but
there's got to be some connective tissue
and so you might be very different but
then the task early on is we'll find the
connective tissue it could be sex it
could be physical attraction truly i
mean that's kept a lot of couples
together because you know yeah but wow
we're just really here we are still
really into each other whatever it is
that's that's the task find what that
connective tissue is be
okay how do you feel about
couples working together what if that's
the connective tissue
do they work together
yeah
um
for some couples that works very very
well and for some couples that
um that masks a relationship in other
words that makes it seem like they're
connected when in essence they're not
um and so yeah they work together well
but all their conversations are about
work they don't really talk about
themselves or the relationship just
about the relationship as work partners
just about what do we do with this
account and this this and this this but
yeah how do we feel about one another
what do i need from you that i'm not
getting what do you need for me that
you're not getting those conversations
don't take place
it becomes very transactional that's
also going to be a recipe for eventual
disengagement because
you know
work is great but then they're going to
have a vacation and realize now what and
then those are the all the kids all they
talk about is the kids because it's the
one connection they have and they avoid
any other conversation again it's not a
recipe that's gonna
last or bring happiness
long term you really have to and i kind
of believe that two people can find that
common ground but they have to mutually
look for it they have to be open to
exploring with one another opening
themselves up you know like really
trying to get to know one another like
you've been together for a while but get
to know one another again do you know
what she's thinking you know what he's
feeling you know like
if you put in that work you can usually
find the common ground but it's got to
be mutual and and you know and
intentional
okay
what would common ground look like if
you don't have common ground with
somebody like how do you dive into them
and try and figure out where the
commonalities are
how do you even start that
it's kind of exactly as you said it in
fact you just dive in and start to see
where the commonalities are again
couples have been together for a while
don't ask each other things because they
think they know each other so well they
don't have to ask they don't ask well
what are you thinking about what i'm
saying on the news right now or i just
read this what do you think about that
and that's not in a domain it could be
something they read that's nothing to do
with one of them that they don't know
like oh i just saw that this happened in
the world what do you think about that
and it could be an area of the world i
never even spoke about before like but
explore that like hey i've never done i
don't know i use this pottery i've never
done pottery um
you want to give that a try like
search for things that you would do i
know we really travel well together
let's organize some weekend trips and
explore places i'll organize one you
organize the other
if you go about literally that search
like go on the on the on the hints you
have of what works well between you but
just be open-minded and truly kind of
explore
uh what you think about certain things
or what interests you um you know
couples do this thing where they they
binge watch tv shows
and it's and they feel like oh we're so
connected we binge watch the edition
like if you didn't talk between the
episodes you're not because it could
have been anyone sitting next to you
like if you pause between episodes and
hey what do you think about that or wow
what was good what did you like what do
you think will happen even if there's a
few minutes of conversation about it
you're making it a mutual experience
otherwise it's like parallel play with
kids he's playing with one he's playing
with another but they're not really
interacting it's less connective so you
wanna you can make it more connected
again there's an intentionality that
happens with that
that should happen with it
okay and
is this kind of
getting to know the other person is that
something you have to do for your entire
relationship if it's a 50-year long
relationship you just have to keep
finding this common ground or does that
just happen sometimes
okay you made that sound very exhausting
which it can be and i don't think it
needs to be continual you know but i
think that because you you know like you
don't you don't have to work on things
all the time but you there are periods
where you'll feel things are working
well and there are periods where you'll
feel you're drifting or
things feel a little bit different
and that's when you have to work on
things so as long as one of you as long
as you check in with each other every
once in a while hey how are we doing
i noticed we've not been talking as much
or we seem to be a little bit on edge
maybe we should talk about how we're
doing and maybe we need to you know like
make some effort to
do whatever it is that we need from one
another like doing those check-ins you
know we go to physical check-ups usually
past a certain age or you go once a year
to get your blood work done
at least once or twice a year get your
emotional temperature taken you know
with your partner to me i would think
over a long course of relationship and
then if there's a little bit of
something then address it
that makes sense um how do you know when
you're near the beginning of a
relationship how do you know if you're
falling in love with the person or
what you think that person is especially
if the relationship is new
an amazing question and here's the
depressing answer yet don't
um because at the beginning of a
relationship you have a few dots of
information
would you connect to make a
you know a a a
mona lisa
but that mona lisa is made from like 10
or 15 days you know dots on the canvas
not from
the you know exquisite brush strokes
you're filling in a lot of blanks with
assumptions yeah but ton
so you don't know um it's always a
process of getting to know and reminding
yourself
as unromantic as it sounds like don't
know everything yet here are a couple of
milestones i always point out number one
if you don't know how the person fights
when they're really angry
then you don't
know them yet because i know a lot of
people who are great but when they lose
it they go from zero to
raving
really quickly
and if you haven't seen that side of
them and you might not for months
because things are wonderful and
honeymoon period and all of that but
then suddenly you see if if they're not
able to you know they can get angry but
if they're not able to communicate or to
resolve conflict or if they just act out
or if they really lose it that might be
a
big issue in a relationship which you
might not find out about
for a while
and the other thing is you don't know
how they are under stress some people
for example i say have you traveled
together because some people travel
great and some people the minute you
give them a plane ticket in their hand
become a ball of annoying stress they're
irritable and they're sharp and they're
sweating and they're panicked and
they're anxious and it's like this is
not a fun way to start
a holiday um but you don't know that you
know until all that they've been a
really stressful time at work how do
they manage stress can they
lean on you are you able to help them
did they shut you out do they so there's
certain things that you don't find out
early on
but they're actually crucial for the
potential longevity
uh or you know viability of a
relationship so you you have to remember
that you're still you know when we're
dating we're putting forth our best
selves right this is the this is the
brochure version you get this is the
pamphlet this is that everything's you
know like people should be on that best
behavior it doesn't tell you what to
northern behavior is it just tells you
what their efforts are
that's really smart that seems somewhat
obvious but i suppose if you're in the
honeymoon period and you've just started
dating someone you're like yeah we never
argue it's great we're never stressed
out we're just happy together
everything's perfect it's like no no
matter who you're going out with
you just haven't seen them angry yet you
haven't seen them stressed yet right and
and maybe they're an angel when they are
maybe you're not an angel but maybe
they're very manageable and you're like
oh wow this is you stressed that's great
or this is you able to communicate when
we have a problem like if you one of the
things i always say to people bring this
up early in a relationship even if it's
very mild bring up an issue
because it's symbolic of how somebody
deals like if you on you know date
number five
say
uh bring up and say hey i just wanted to
bring something up i'm really enjoying
you know seeing you but this is the
fifth time you've been a little bit late
and i just want to say i'm someone who
doesn't do well with that so i just
wanted to bring that to your attention
just to let you know that if you could
make efforts i'd really appreciate it i
understand that it can happen but
you say it nicely you say it and if they
go like
and they might say like oh you know i'm
sorry i'll sorry i know i'm like that i
will definitely try and make an effort
that's nice if they go like well what do
you mean i'm late so i was so late why
are you making a big deal out of it and
you said it nicely and that's their
response that's also informative right
but you can get that information pretty
early on by being very nice in terms of
how you bring up a small thing just to
see how they discuss it
that's sneaky i like that
i can remember
when i was
i used to have health problems which i
do not anymore thank goodness
but when i was doing my like tinder
dating which was just kind of going out
for coffee trying to meet people
i can remember i was late one time and
somebody snapped at me and it was like
date two
and i was late and they snapped me and i
was like ho ho
and then i snapped back at them
it just didn't go well anyway good
memories
day two is inappropriate for them to
snap at you they should actually be nice
so that revealed something you know that
had you not been late
you wouldn't have found out so so that's
what i'm saying right but that's the
thing bug them a bit see what happens
right so when everything goes perfectly
it's not that everything's perfect is
that you don't quite know yet
it might be it certainly might yeah you
don't know yet
okay
let's see
i have a whole bunch of questions i want
to ask you i just need to pick which
ones
okay this is a little bit different so
um i told you i've been kind of delving
into trauma and how to recover from
trauma
so
how do you recover from shared traumatic
experiences so that you're not setting
each other off by reminding them of the
trauma you guys both have gone through
what a great question and that's a bit
of a tricky one i think over this past
year and a half a lot of people have
been through
yeah yeah experiences quarantining
together
well yeah but you know like i mean i
live in new york city the you know it
was it was the epicenter at the
beginning a lot of people here
have this look and they tell you oh the
sirens because that first
month people were just locked in their
apartments afraid to go outside and all
you had were sirens day and night every
several times an hour you just couldn't
get away from it and so
the sirens were so traumatic it felt
like the end of the world and um yeah
but how you get over trauma
number one is that two things i want to
say about that that are a little
counterintuitive for people most people
think that the psychologist would say
oh if it's trauma you have to talk about
it you've got to bring it out you've got
to like you know get it out of your
system you have to debrief about it
that's not necessarily true there are
people when they've been through
traumatic events that feel the need
to talk about them
and if you feel the need to talk about
the traumatic events you should but
there are people who go through the same
traumatic event and actually feel the
need to not
talk about it they feel that they'd
rather compen compartmentalize it and
just kind of move on i don't want to
talk about it i just want to move on and
for those people who don't want to talk
about it who are able to
compartmentalize and move on being
forced to talk about it
can actually be more scarring
than not after 9 11 in new york city
there was one study that showed that the
more people spoke
about the events the harder it was for
them
to move past them that the people who
experienced similar events but didn't
talk about them because they didn't want
to
um did better long term so it's an
individual thing you need to know
whether you feel the need to talk and
some people definitely feel the need to
i don't want to deal with it i just want
to move on
and and if you're the move on type then
it's not great for you to talk and if
you're the talker type it's important
and so
that
is also important when it's to people
because you hope to be matched there i
mean
often it's one person like i really want
to talk and the other person i really
don't
because i don't want to get
re-traumatized every time you have a
memory you're kind of
really you're laying down that memory
again and so you're bringing it up in a
traumatic way you're actually making
that trauma
worse and so for the person who doesn't
want to do it it's not wise for them to
then maybe the other person should find
you know someone to talk to who does
want to talk about things
but even to have that conversation
what's your preference to something you
want to talk about etc
the other thing about trauma just the
most you know known thing about trauma
is that the best way through it
is to um find meaning and you can only
do that in a certain distance of time
and and and emotional distance but to
find meaning to have a way to extract
something from that event that it taught
you that it showed you that you could
make changes based on and then it has
purpose or utility even if it was very
very difficult and that often takes that
edge
off
uh you know what the trauma
does
or the scars that it leaves
yeah
purposeless suffering is much much worse
than suffering and learning something or
being able to help somebody because you
experience something or yeah
something like that does
so you talked about how some people are
better or they prefer to
compartmentalize versus talk about it
does that have a lot to do with how soon
after the traumatic experience occurred
they're trying to delve into it like if
they wait a certain amount of time
then do some people go from
compartmentalizing it's hard to say to
talking about it
oh yeah i mean there can be an initial
shock period literally um these uh you
know the the in when there's certain you
know um
mass events then then you have most
people who experience uh trauma or shock
are actually taken to hospitals for
evaluation the the non-physically
damaged are also taken to hospitals and
they're considered among
because they are injured now that
initial shock um
subsides you know after however many
hours or days and then what are you left
with and so it may be in those in that
first few moments where you're still
coming to terms with what what happened
here um it's hard to tell are you
somebody who needs to talk or or not but
in the days after again you will feel
that need
once that shock is passed a bit to to
want to talk about it or you'll feel the
need to i don't and you'll know that
very clearly and it's very it's similar
with grief when people lose a relative
sometimes the assumption is because we
have all these rituals about the
community coming together to talk about
things but sometimes some people like
can we just not talk about them though
because i i i'm
up for the distraction but i just don't
want to talk that's too painful for me
to talk about that
so even in grief sometimes people can
can have that choice but you know it
because you you feel like oh i don't
want to do this or i really want to do
this i wish somebody could listen
you know that about yourself
yeah
it's complicated
i've had a number of experiences i
wouldn't recommend i mean everybody has
and i've noticed
depending on the experience i'll either
go into i don't want to talk about it
like don't try and get into my head and
dissect whatever i'm thinking don't want
to talk about it
to oh i need to write about it or you
know talking to a therapist would help
um depending on how tough the situation
is maybe sometimes it takes a certain
period of time then i'm like okay now i
can talk about it but it's been a year
and you said something very important
there and that's the the the writing
part because
writing is super super super useful
because it helps you it's private so you
don't have to share it with someone but
it helps you organize your thoughts
because when we have
those big feelings attached to whatever
the traumatic event
was
then it's sometimes hard to you know
like when you're feeling that it's hard
to organize your thoughts because you're
feeling something so strongly it kind of
shuts down the minute we go back to our
more primitive uh
in terms of evolution uh more primitive
structures it takes away from our
executive functioning from the newer
ones and so our you know the more upset
we are the the less
thinking we can do with clarity
writing forces emotional distance
because to translate what the thought
and feeling is into words that you then
organize and actually do the fine motor
skill of writing them down or typing
them
it is a laborious uh mental execution
that actually creates emotional distance
and then lowers the emotional response
enough for you to have more clarity in
your thinking about it so it's very
useful as a way to especially when
you're feeling
a lot of things to to or you're feeling
things very strongly to organize your
thoughts to get your own bearings before
you then
you know like a lot of people say like i
can't talk to somebody to know what i
think first or what i feel first well
writing is a great way to get in touch
with it
okay i love that i've found writing
really useful um when i was
actually i still do this sometimes if i
get really really wound up in an
argument or there's too many things
going on in my brain
and i'm in an argument with somebody
sometimes i find arguing over
by writing is actually
a good way to ease into that when i was
like going back to my first relationship
in high school
before texting was really a thing
i would
and maybe this was weird but if i got
really mad about something i'd write it
down so i'd be able to tell them that
way but i didn't have the
i was too stressed out or worried just
like i can't talk about this but like
this is why i'm angry
i found that really useful even though
it kind of felt like cheating
i don't think it's cheating at all
look for for someone like me um the the
ideal there is
what makes the communication best
right i mean that's the goal like what
allows you to communicate
best and for you if you were to talk
about it and you would get upset and
then it would be harder to articulate
what's going on with you versus writing
it down again with that emotional
distance it forces and the ability to
articulate things because you can go and
you can edit and you can truly and some
people actually the you know our verbal
expression and our written expression is
not
in line with a lot of people some people
are much stronger in one than the other
they can speak amazingly write poorly or
vice versa
so you writing was you communicating as
clearly as you could so to me that's the
win
right i mean that's the smart thing to
do and i sometimes recommend to couples
who've been together for a long time if
they're explosive if they tend to kind
of go from zero to war of the roses in
like two sentences do it via text do it
via you know emails because
the other person won't interrupt you
they won't you know like speak over you
they won't start yelling when you're in
the middle of what you want to say you
actually get to finish what you say they
get to finish what they say so if you're
having trouble communicating because
it's too explosive do it in text do it
and writing that to me that's that's not
a cheat and it's actually the more
efficient
way to do it sometimes
okay that makes sense or if you're the
type of person like you said that's
explosive or you're gonna get mad and
say something you don't mean if you're
writing it down then you can say okay
scratch that that isn't good exactly you
write it and then you take it out
exactly right
okay that's really helpful information
uh let's see
um i think i kind of asked this earlier
but
how do you know
okay i've seen couples that will stay
together for a very long period of time
and
from the outside it just doesn't look
any good
and you can see that from the outside
but because they're in the relationship
they can't see that so are there signs
people should look for to know whether
or not they should just end the
relationship like you you talked about
people
staying together or having kids so they
had something in common when they don't
um
are there signs you've seen in couples
where you're like
stop torturing yourselves
oh yeah um the
the research on on couples is such that
most couples therapists
can watch like a five-minute
snippet of a couple argue
and predict a divorce with accuracies of
over 90
oh
that's rough
hmm as a therapist i tend to think it's
great but okay yes
but it's not for the couple who's
arguing in that way why but why that is
is because it is how couples argue
that gives you a window into the
relationship satisfaction and longevity
it's how they process conflict and
there's several factors that have been
shown to you know bode well for couples
versus bowed poorly for couples here's
one factor that bodes well i'll give you
one of each
bodes well um there's something called
bids bids is you're sitting with your
partner and your partner you know reads
something in the paper and goes oh wow
this is really interesting
that's a bid to connect
because you're then supposed to say oh
what is it and then they tell you when
you go oh wow oh they saw that if they
so if they say oh wow this is really
interesting and you're like can't you
see i'm working
not so good so the couples that offer
bids and respond to them have a great
prognosis um it's a very positive sign
that you're offering bids to connect
small minor moments right and i gave
this example of a minor minor minor
moment but if you think of these
moments as that was a bid to connect
um and you respond to it that's very
good for couples um
what's very bad for couples is when in
an argument you quickly get to content
and you can see that and i've seen that
in my office and i've seen that
unfortunately at dinner parties where
you can see that one person annoys the
other and there's contempt there either
on the face
or
or in the language like like almost
discussed in how they're talking like
how could you even like with this like
facial expression that's just
makes you want to like as an observer
makes you want to oof that was very very
harsh but couples are doing that to each
other in public or they're you know they
get there very quickly that's such a bad
sign because if you so quickly lose the
connection lose the love or respect you
have for that person and go so quickly
to contempt which is truly the opposite
of love and respect
then
that foundation is not solid in any way
shape
or form
um and so there's certain things like
you know there's contempt or there's you
know there's a lot of
jokes that you make at the other
person's expense
if it's mild if it's truly funny if it's
not a big deal for the other person but
you sometimes hear it and you can see
the other person flash hurt in their
eyes and this was at a dinner party and
you're like
did you know you just wounded
emotionally you just hurt their feelings
in public and embarrass them like
why possibly would you do that it
happens all the time so those kinds of
things
are not good signs and putting out bids
and responding to them are good signs
okay
what do couples who are at the contempt
stage do is there a way to reverse that
yes but
in one condition only if both of you are
of a mind to do that because it will
require both of you to change a habit
that depends on both of you and that's
how you're arguing
you need to learn to argue more
productively you need to learn to argue
with more empathy and compassion you
need to slow it down to understand
the other person before you get angry
with them like they said something
that's annoying why did they say it do
they really think that tell me more
about where that came from like you need
to be able to slow it down and get to
understand things
it is
a big emotional effort in that moment
what your insights are telling you is
lash out flash up you know and so you
have to
control that you have to actually do the
you know the thing of like managing and
regulating your feelings and doing the
difficult thing and doing it because you
hope that they will afford you the same
courtesy and you can flip a dynamic
from a very negative one into a positive
one but it takes a lot of work this is
where work would be a lot of work and
there are couples and there are many who
determine that we really want this to
work we got into this bad habit let's
really work on changing it and when they
really work together that's what couples
therapists do all the time they can
but if one of them is in and the other
one is like i don't think i want to do
it it's not going to work and certainly
if both are not of mine to do it or they
just don't have any rope left because
they just
i can't i can't deal with this anymore
then it's not going to work
okay how do you identify a good couples
therapist
are there places to go or yeah good
question yes um there are physical it's
do not assume that any therapist has
been trained as a couple's therapist
it's fair when you're going to a
couple's therapist to say may i ask
um
where you trained in couples therapy and
if they say oh you know i took a class
and i've just done it over the years
you know if it's a referral from people
who know them and said yeah they were
great maybe but most people will be able
to say i did a master's program in
couples of family therapy i did four
years of training plus a post-doc
in couples in family therapy and then i
taught it for for many years in other
words you if you find people who've
actually got that credential who've
actually learnt it in clear programs who
teach it who are known for it they're
going to be much more skilled at doing
it it's very different modality than
individual therapy you have to be much
more active as a couple's therapist if
you take your eye off the ball again
think of an explosive couples if you get
lost in your own thought for a minute
suddenly world war iii is going on in
your office and you're like oops how did
that happen
so you've got to be really on it you
have to be able to really multitask and
think of what's going on here here and
in your head about what needs to happen
it's so you know you want somebody who's
either been referred because they've
done a very good job with somebody you
know or you very fair to ask and by the
way if you're asking any
physician or any therapist about their
specific skill set oh you do this where
did you learn it and they get defensive
um
no yeah not a good sign it's a very very
fair question there's zero reason to get
defensive i get asked that still and you
know i'm at a certain level of people
just i have a waiting list of people
waiting to see me i still get asked did
you learn this
i think very fair question i will tell
them if i did and if i didn't i'll say
no so maybe i'm not the best person for
you
yeah you don't need a volatile therapist
trying to help your volatility right
you want somebody well trained if you're
volatile right you want somebody who you
know can manage
the situation and help you rather than
just feel overwhelmed by what's going on
that makes sense okay how do you tell
when someone you've been talking with
for a while
whether or not they're interested in you
that seems like a simple question but
i'm gonna ask it anyway
two things number one don't look at
anything they say only at what they do
so literally ignore words you know they
say oh no i'm really interested and
you're so great and the
what are the actions
who's initiating the get-togethers how
quickly are they contacting you
after you get together um how quickly do
they respond to your texts how much are
they writing literally counting
sentences counting lines how many lines
did they write to how many lines that
you're writing um and so
you can see this is somebody who seems
like they're pursuing me or that they're
interested and they might not be
pursuing but they're very responsive
you know it's text messages if it takes
you more than 24 hours to respond
you'd have better been in
you know in surgery either as a the
surgeon or the person getting surgery um
like there's this it's there's no if
you're interested there's very little
circumstance maybe you're traveling that
there's very little circumstance in
which you can't just say sorry busy but
i'll text tomorrow like something that's
responsive
um or let someone know you know i'm
going into this very busy week i won't
be able to like but you know a lot of
times people are like well i texted and
i didn't hear back i'm still waiting the
date went so well but it's been two days
and i'm like
they're not trying to let you know that
they're interested maybe they still are
but and maybe and then when they come
back on day three do they go i'm so
sorry i got so swamped with work or do
they pretend like no that's normal that
we spent five hours together on sunday
and it's wednesday before i say
something
that shows a little bit less interest to
me right and so and again if they
address it and say oh i'm sorry i was
you know then they're at least aware
that no one there was an intention there
to communicate
soon or more quickly so you know i think
oftentimes people have that gut feeling
they kind of know they just want to hope
that maybe it's more positive than it
feels but when somebody is interested
you usually feel it because they make
you feel
they're interested and if you don't feel
it
then it's maybe to
know not no it's maybe but if that you
know when it is
that totally makes sense
okay what happens if you're texting
somebody
and
they're not responding very well so it's
not going very well and you're like
forget it but then every time you don't
respond for a while they'll ping you
again
um
it's such a common pattern right and
it's so frustrating to people
when that happens
and i think that the response to that
should be um
when they ping you again how long do
they wait to pig you
you wait that long to respond and
when you do respond say oh hey you know
i was busy but to be honest with you i'm
happy to get together again if you want
but unless you know i don't really have
a ton of time for just texting for
another month before we do that so
kind of you know
people get off the pot or you know like
you can
just be very clear about it like look i
had a fun time but um
if you want to get together and explore
another date that's fine if not no
problem but you know it's
i i don't don't have time to do the back
and forth too much i mean you can say it
nicely in some way yeah but you know
yeah it's reasonable to expect that you
know because that's a classic pattern of
somebody that's putting you on hold or
keeping you or not really serious so
yeah you don't have to comply with it
you can just say like hey you know what
um you seem
busy or otherwise preoccupied so it was
nice to know you but you know if you
want to check in with me when you have
the bandwidth that's great and otherwise
we'll you know see each other around
whatever you say do it nicely obviously
you want to leave the door open a little
bit but you want to be clear then
[Music]
okay that makes sense is that um just
between like a relationship between a
man and a woman
is that more normal for a man to be less
responsive or is that a sign that you
should maybe
not be as interested as you are
men will tell me is this normal for a
woman to be this unresponsive she must
be getting so many you know swipes okay
i'm just one of them and and women
always say well you know he's always
so i really think it kind of goes both
ways depending on the person but here's
what i say i'm like
when you're texting with someone right
it might go from you know a day to
texting or texting to a date but that it
might be the early steps of a
relationship that ends up forming
or not
if it if they are early steps then you
have to understand that you're kind of
negotiating something in an unspoken way
you're negotiating a dynamic and it's a
dynamic that you're agreeing to is
i reach out to you in a timely manner
you don't respond in a timely manner
then i respond in a timely manner then
you don't respond in a time you are
setting up a dynamic in which i will
make more effort in this than you do you
don't have to make as much effort as i
do is the unspoken dynamic that you're
kind of agreeing to which you do not
want
to agree to so that's why you have to
pay attention to these early steps and i
think texting is so useful because you
can literally whenever a patient said to
me i said i want to show your phone
because i want to see in that look they
wrote two lines you wrote six then they
wrote one word then you wrote two lines
you are constantly putting in more
effort than them just visually
and it comes across so you are setting
up this dynamic where you will try
harder and you don't want a set epidemic
where you want something that's more
fluid where there are whole chunks where
they write a lot and then you write a
little then it flips over it's back and
forth but you will often see that it's
very skewed it's like one person making
more effort than the other don't do that
at the beginning you're setting
something up that will be hard to change
later on you are letting them know that
to be with you doesn't take that much
effort and the answer should always be
to be with me takes a little bit of
effort i put in that effort i expect to
get it back
and you can control that with the
texting then you wait also even if
you're dying to respond to them you wait
you go sorry i was busy at work because
it's no biggie for them to be busy at
work it's not biggie for you you
shouldn't make it more urgent for you
than it is for them but pay attention
early on
ah so you have to so you have to be
paying attention you have to kind of
play into that
game to set up boundaries near the
beginning
yes boundaries sounds dynamics
look true but here's the reality and
it's a harsh reality it's like cement
relationship dynamics are like cement
they dry very quickly
and then they harden and it's hard to
change them you can change them before
they're dry at the beginning but they
dry quickly so pay attention to those
small things you are actually
setting up a tacit you know unspoken
agreement to something that you know you
think oh i'll change that later this
event will be drier it'll be way harder
to do that later change it
okay that makes sense
thank you very much for coming on uh if
anybody wants to follow you or learn
more or listen to your podcast where
should they go what should they type in
so they can put in guy winch.com that's
g-u-y-w-i-n
that's my website they'll find links to
my ted talks the podcast podcast is
called dear therapists they can get it
wherever they get their
podcasts and on instagram and twitter
i'm at guy winch and i'm guy winch
author on facebook
perfect thank you very much for coming
on
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
you